la téléconsultation en france ca existe
depuis quelques années inspiré de
projets qui se sont développées de
manière indépendante dans différentes
régions et ça a commencé à vraiment
progresser un peu avant le comique en
fait ça a beaucoup séduit les patients
qui rapidement que les médecins
s'étaient pris le sur les possibilités
que cela ôterait et maintenant comme ils
sont complémentaires à la consultation
point sur le débat qui a été relancé par
les événements tragiques à grenoble en
fait je ne sais pas si c'est le bon
débat qui énonce et c'est à dire que
est-ce que l'erreur qui est qui a
conduit au décès était lié à une erreur
médicale est ce qu'elle était liée à la
téléconsultation c'est très difficile de
le juger
c'est un raccourci qui me semble un peu
rapide oui c'est compliqué de tranchées
de l'extérieur et de vouloir le mettre
ça sur le dos de la modalité
téléconsultation c'est une solution
facile dans la télémédecine ya vraiment
beaucoup de choses on peut vendre la
téléexpertise où on voit qu'elle se
développe progressivement on peut
demander un avis notamment auprès d'un
spécialiste de second recours un
dermatologue et cardiologue
quand on est une question qui se pose en
en cabinet ça on a des choses qui se
développe effectivement il ya un grand
avenir on le sent bien les puits b mais
du point de vue du médecin généraliste
c'est essentiellement la constituent
essentiellement par la téléconsultation
[Musique]
il faut que chaque médecin qui a recours
à l'être les consultations soit
consciente de ses limites à lui et des
limites posées par la téléconsultation
par exemple on peut pas faire de
d'examen des fonctions respiratoires
peut pas examiner des tympans pas il ya
plein de choses qu'on peut pas faire
mais l'idée de la téléconsultation c'est
pour certaines pathologies pour les qui
nécessite pas un examen clinique de
proposer une prise en charge et pour
celle qui nécessite absolument un examen
clinique d'expliquer aux patients ce
qu'il doit faire et si nécessaire de
prendre contact avec un collègue ou le
samu pour faciliter et accélérer la
prise en charge
il faut pas voir la téléconsultation
comme étant l'alpha et l'oméga qui
permettront de répondre à tous les
problèmes de santé à tous les problèmes
de notre système de santé
la loi de l'offre et la demande et la
congruence entre l'offre et la demande
ça n'oublie pas mathématiquement si on
met de la téléconsultation partout tout
le monde a accès d'un ou un médecin
quand ils le souhaitent
je pense que beaucoup de gens vont
déchanter
si jamais on leur vend cette solution là
l'erreur médicale
effectivement on va en avoir hanté les
consultations mais on en a déjà depuis
toujours dans nos cabinets donc elle
n'est pas l'apanage de la
téléconsultation par contre
effectivement en tant que médecin on
doit s'approprier la manière de faire la
médecine derrière une caméra derrière un
ordinateur un téléphone ça ne sera pas
la même médecine que dans un cabinet
médical
si on essaye de faire la même chose
alors que les moyens sont pas les mêmes
c'est là qu'on risque d'aller à l'erreur
est ce qu'on doit en tirer des
conséquences
je pense qu'il ya besoin de plus en plus
dans notre société de responsabilité
chaque acteur dans son parcours de soins
après est-ce qu'il faut mettre une
couche de plus dans l'arsenal législatif
je n'en suis pas certain en tout cas on
a besoin de référentiels côté médical
pour pouvoir juger est ce que ce qui a
été fait et est en cohérence avec les
données de la science disponibles il ya
déjà un cadre légal qui est la venue de
5 de la convention médicale de 2016 qui
porte un cadre législatif à la
téléconsultation qui a été qui est
réévalué à chaque fois qu'il a été
réévaluée pour la crise sanitaire en
autorisant un certain nombre d'actes qui
auparavant n'était pas autorisée je
pense notamment aux interruptions
volontaires de grossesse qui pouvaient
être réalisées lors d'une télé
consultation la prison de chargement en
orthophonie a pu être pris à lui avoir
lieu pendant la crise sanitaire pour
répondre à un réel besoin parce que les
patients ne nous est plus se rendre ou
n'avait pas l'autorisation pendant le
confinement de se rendre de déplacés où
c'était difficile après il ya des
sociétés savantes qui sont en train de
mettre en place des des recommandations
de bonnes prises en charge ont été les
consultations
donc ça a déjà été fait notamment pour
les antibiothérapie par la société
française de pédiatrie et le collège
national des médecins généralistes
moi même je suis en train de je suis
impliqué dans un travail sur la bonne
pratique en maladies infectieuses
il faut que ce soit cadré par la loi
mais sans entrer dans un enfer
administratif